[Music]
it's funny even though we haven't been
together that long i can't believe it's
only been three months it feels like
forever
when you know you know
babe
from the moment that i saw your face
looking up at me griffin save it for the
real proposal the real proposal mm-hmm
tomorrow night at our new year's eve
party is this a joke i think it's for
the best to dump me the night before my
sister's wedding
what am i going to do i can't just pick
up some random guy off the street
i live here i live here
i live in norwood 15 maple drive you're
not in norwood you're in westwood what
this is crazy but my sister is getting
married and the ex was supposed to be my
plus one and i can't show up without a
date i really can't of course i mean i
sound psycho no no not at all
yes i'd have to leave by eight
hey clown where are you that i had to
make a quick stop it's almost nine time
for pictures oh i'll be right over there
was that a bride quick stop was at a
wedding um
i wouldn't get mom you're being crazy
that's him right there not much to look
at but seems nice i want to hear how you
two met i guess you could say i caught
her by surprise it's been a non-stop
adventure
it's an impressive speech it was
surprisingly effortless
margo
kip yep i thought he was kip well don't
look at me i have no idea but the new
kip is hot
not the cake do you mess up the cake
no we're good
you like him so he's proposing to
someone else he doesn't love me
if he's so in love with her
what's he doing at a wedding with you
i saw you i felt something that i've
never felt before
and i do the right thing
you know when the universe gives you a
gift
you don't just say no
[Music]
but i still get to
[Music]
choose science is closed let's break in
wait i cannot show up without the veil
are you crazy i'm bringing a stranger to
my sister's wedding
do i look like i make good decisions
under pressure
you